hi Chris how are you I'm doing great I'm
doing okay
I'm trying to figure out what's gonna
happen at the all-star break with the
two captains and now that we get to see
the draft we get to see who's taking and
you know LeBron said hey I'm all for
letting you see this but then he didn't
want to tell us who his team was or how
he drafted his team so what do you think
of this new idea that we actually get to
see the captains picking their teams
well I will cause everybody for
excitement first I heard the
announcement but there's no official
details so you know that that you know
I'd be careful with that you know but I
think it could be good I think that
you'll see who two friends are what
alliances are some guys picked friends
over talent or vice versa I do think
though that it'll incentivize guys to
play hard so imagine if I'm the eighth
pick tape and I'm the man I'm from you
come from wherever and I'm you know I'm
ticked off about being picked so late
hopefully it will you know instead of us
guys to play harder because they don't
like what everyone kind of like when
you're picked in the league and you
don't like how low you were picked and
you go all year trying to prove that you
were a higher pick than that so I think
there definitely could be a lot of a lot
of benefits I think the team's would be
closer with chemistry the coach in an
all-star game really doesn't matter and
I think that this will help coaches
reinforce reinforce what coaches won't
play hard look for each other things
like that because every guy wants to do
it because he feels like he's been left
now so I think it could be a great thing
and I'm excited to see how it plays out
but the only thing I don't like these
are greatest players in the world and
and today with all these Twitter finger
gangsters players people that know and
he's don't like the fact that someone
has to be regulated to being last and
have to hear about that we really got
one of the best 24 players in the world
who would you pick if I gave you the
first first pick Durant okay period you
wouldn't worry over handle oh oh period
Syria you wouldn't worry about up and
sang LeBron
you wouldn't worry about upsetting I
[Laughter]
mean it's like at the park no I wouldn't
care about picking home okay if all my
legends were alive I would pick will
first I wouldn't care what anyone else
said I wouldn't care
wait you take over Jordan I would take
Wilk first period really yeah I'll get
other pics cuz you can go with Georgia
Tech I'll get I'll get the logo you go
with him I'll get magic you go with
someone else
I'll get Shaq and make him look forward
you go with someone else I'll get kuzey
you go someone else you know I mean
Pistol Pete like I you know yeah I
definitely was started off though with
that but I would take see how he takes
Shack over wilt okay I definitely could
see that the ran hurdles world is still
one of the greatest avoiding the
greatest athletes and even if those two
you know kind of negated each other you
know we still got more pics you know
what I mean so it would be now that
would be awesome in order to be able to
somehow do that but I wouldn't be
worried about not taking the Brawn but I
do think that you'll see you know maybe
you know guys with the lionesses pick
each other or how does agents play into
it now the fact that your agent might
save you hey man come on we need our
rosters you know in our agency to be to
pick the first step you know there's
gonna be a lot of muck little games and
that's not what I'm looking for so let's
enjoy the first couple of years while
hopefully it says innocent as they can
be before it starts going to you know
some other stuff but I'm definitely
looking forward to it in here Durant
would be my first pick or if I'm going
to state I'll try to take all Golden
State players everything it's gonna get
interesting if I'm gonna eat what if I
want all east because people been
talking junk about how weak the East is
or if I'm indeed not get a pick or and
not that he would get to pick I don't
know how they're gonna choose the
captains but maybe
he picks all big fellas what if it was
in be Anthony Davis what is it was just
all 7-footers you know once I mean it
could be some interesting things going
on especially when guys get upset you
know about the third 4:7 picot meaning
not the guys to get got picked but the
captain says while you take my guy you
know I wanted him so I think there'll be
a lot of gamesmanship and I actually
think is gonna be really fun hopefully
the way they do it the first few years
what if I said you could have let's say
boogie cousins was completely healthy
and playing the way did last year before
he got hurt I gave you Golden State's
roster or you could have the rest of the
NBA for your all-star team a Dion dream
you know put Kauai on Duran you know so
not that I would work but at least yeah
they would have the chemistry they would
have the advantage in the chemistry but
I think defensively in size you know I
could I could get some other people but
I thought was you're gonna say was if
boogie cousins was healthy what I think
you know him Durant who's taller than
boogie cousins everybody needs to know
that Duran was seven feet ad embiid and
let's go yo kovitch Oh daddy no what am
I talking about
let's go to Greek the point guard what
am I talking about and then uh I love to
see that big versus littles you never
know man I think we got a lot of options
in this you're gonna be excited just
kind of running through the options of
what the all-star game could be all
right I want to know we're talking to
Chris Weber he's on the call tonight
rockets and the Thunder at 8:00 Eastern
what did you see when you saw the Duke
freshman the other night honestly I
didn't watch the game I went back and
saw some of the highlights and I think
Coach K is a great coach a better person
and it's probably not a better place to
be if you're a group of freshmen that
want to play well win and move on to
your career
so I'm excited to watch these guys
didn't bring back any thoughts to the
fam 5 for you you know like what all the
comparisons very honestly when I saw the
cover the fabulous five I thought how
would y'all do that to these kids
because you remember three years ago or
four years ago that that's how long
that's how funny it is I don't even
remember who was on the so-called best
team ever with Kentucky they said they
would have destroyed us and all that
yeah I don't I don't know who's on that
team and I'm not dogged and what I'm
saying is that until you do it I don't
really care about all that other stuff
like that was a great first game and I'm
happy about desiring like I love the
young kids I want them to do well but as
far as the narrative you know you got a
long way to go and because it's a long
season I'm sure Coach K is telling them
you know we won one game so what you
know you have all the media you have
everybody loves used to store your life
people love you jump off the bandwagon
what happens when that versity it's what
happens for player gets hurt what
happens when guys are stilling
themselves and they don't go to class or
they don't run in practice I'm not
saying that's them I'm saying those are
the traps of anybody being talented and
so my whole thing is I was just like why
why would you doing that today and I and
the last thing our class can't be
compared with any other freshman class
period ma Harriette there's no such
there's no Christian Laettner in college
no Bobby Hurley in college you name it
lay me one for your player that's going
top five in the NBA mmm no thank you cuz
the year I cuz the year that I played
them you know who was the first ticket
was shot in the second pick I think it
was Christian Laettner didn't the third
pick it was Alonzo Mourning and I'm not
talking about them I know people are
gonna more but I don't even I don't even
look at comparing us to anyone else
because I am is I want to add a lifetime
athlete and so I love watching them and
playing I love but the comparison is
just stupid there's no seniors there's
no seniors or juniors that could have
played in the NBA if you could play in
the NBA you're in the NBA so you're
playing against competition that's not
name yes which is you have to play who's
ahead of you and they're killing edge or
that thing but I don't I don't get it
all
comparisons I never compared my favorite
team UNLV with us and I'm not gonna
compare my other favorite team the Fab
five with other teams you know thirty
years later that colleges College has
changed you know so I thought well I
just thought that with the hype of it
because there is so much hype with the
Fab five we had not seen this before and
you know the way you guys looked and
acted in your age and just the style
like everything about it it was like
whoa whoa whoa we were playing again we
were playing but we were playing against
Bobby Knight and Calbert Cheaney Player
of the Year as a senior well your plan
to get Jim's accident Ohio State Big
Ten's Player of the Year as a senior we
weren't scared than any other freshman I
mean of the best press in the world were
our friends there was Glenn Robinson and
you know Alan Henderson just a few other
guys across the country the best
freshman it was you know ten and five
went to Michigan so you know I that's
all I'm saying it was just we do not
respect the play of Bobby Hurley
Christian Laettner we do not respect to
play of Kenny Anderson you know that
does all them since these Smith as a
senior yeah yeah you know that's all I'm
saying the context is so so so much
different that's just I just you know
want to continue to remember that there
was a different a different culture than
one where if you were 22 years old you
were being drafted into the NBA not 19
you know it's a little bit different but
they're so exciting to watch that you
know if if a hater out there wants to to
say that I'm hating well maybe the only
reason why you would hate because they
are so spectacular you want to distance
yourself by years and contexts from
anything but it's their time now Dan
like it's their time now and I'm excited
just to watch and see what they're gonna
do and I would say them raise the bar do
some crazy
let's go like don't don't have that
moniker and not shock the world in
something don't don't
let's go which what you're gonna show me
I can't wait to see Zion come from the
free-throw line
jumping over five cheerleaders as he
goes out on the break do whatever you
got to do but you know just keeping at
endless and I'm really looking forward
and I'm happy for the young man because
they have a coach like Coach K that can
help them both on the court and off the
court which is so important but
I own waste to 85 Chris that's amazing
that is that's that's something else I
mean I don't know we should I don't know
if we should talk to them and tell them
look you could go out right now to
Kansas City Chiefs easy buddy
I don't even linebacker you could play
running back it could be the new running
fullback ugly can he catch no I love
that kid and how humble he is and I've
been watching him a long time and so
being seeing his consistency and and and
how he's been is just is awesome for for
a fan like me to watch it so I'm so
excited I wish these kids the best I
hope they break every record
individually collectively and and just
chase their dreams it's gonna be fun to
watch them go but at the end of day they
got to do it they got to do it right
before I let you go if you were 18 now
coming out of high school and you could
go to the G League and they're gonna pay
125 thousand you could go maybe with
LeBron and rich Paul and his agency and
have an internship and then train and
get ready for the draft or you could go
to Michigan or Duke for one year what
would you do now so let's take the backs
when I was coming out of college my
favorite players right there Barkley
Birds Jordan magic so let's say rich
Paul was one of their guys when I came
out yep
I reached on the phone like what you
need me to do really is to be around
great yeah to be around greatness you
know what I mean because it's rich as
rich is great he's a wonderful guy but
his story is what makes him great is
that he came from the same place he's
friends with LeBron he was patient went
through the struggles with LeBron the
frustration like he knows if I went
through something he could say well when
we went through this is what we would do
you know who would have better advice on
life skills of getting out of situations
any situations or how to take care of
your body know how to play basketball or
who's the best trainer during the
no I definitely would you know I nothing
they don't have more than that
you guys know and the tribal still isn't
good you know what I mean them really
the best scenario is ones you probably
didn't mention and that's to go overseas
and see the world because the players
that I know that play overseas has a
different which have a different way
about them you know when you're 18 you
go out and see the world and how the
world is it really busts all of your
stereotypes about culture and from the
players that I've kind of mentor and
have gone over there it's really they
come back much much more mature I think
they say the 21 year olds their age that
has stayed here so I think that that or
or definitely working with a guy like a
like a LeBron Ariz fall would be
sometimes you get to work out with you
know I wouldn't want to plan to levy I'd
want to work out with a Brian all summer
if I could be around greatness all
summer and see what he does on summer
that's all I need and I was not playing
pick-up with guys don't want to make it
won't pass the ball because they got to
show the coach they can make the shot
so no no it's pretty cool seeing you
back at Michigan on the sidelines there
but uh that was there's a lot of fun man
I was uh I was pretty cool man
talking to the team and first of all
coach Brown on defense man he all he did
was already of his tip is hats emotional
it's like I wanted I want to play it was
it was emotional at times my father was
there he definitely enjoyed it so it was
a lot of reminiscing for us it was you
know it's all been well he being in that
football stadium I had been there so
long and you know just just the memories
things that were said things that I've
gone through with certain people seeing
a lot of the old athletic staff that was
there and very honestly just being a
humble bah bahah ball asking me I know a
lot of people have strong opinions about
him one way or another and for me yeah
it it obviously is gonna help you know
with some recruiting it's I'm just gonna
help because it gives a great story and
obviously you know you could overdo the
kumbaya
but but to me it was wow this guy really
cuz for years he asked me that and it
was like man you're coming you're coming
I'm an athlete you're nice if you play
here and I'd like to just thank him for
forcing it that the issue because him
doing that made me ready you know and so
it was an awesome moment of him some
money glad I got to share with my father
and go out there and most importantly we
won the flip and we won the game so it
wasn't my fault
it was a great experience just as motion
yes it was fun and no you know it was it
was a blessing for me to have that
moment with my father had that moment my
father so it was cool Chris will be
calling tonight's rockets Thunder game
that starts at 8:00 Eastern on TNT part
of the 39 doubleheader great to talk to
you Chris
safe travels thanks for joining us
that's a c-webb joining us for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]